That was like.
Well, here we are
taking one of our world
famous breaks from filming.
With a nice bit of
weather for it, you know?
Yeah. Nice and rainy.
We thought we'd get the fancy China out
and have a little bit of Coke.
It's got all flowers on it and everything!
What's that?
I think it's a tea strainer.
Tea strainer, put some Coke in there.
Ah, ah.
What have you done?
I've just wrecked the tablecloth.
Well that's no good.
We should change this tablecloth,
but I can't be bothered to move
all of this laid out stuff.
It's so pretty.
I know! I've got an idea.
Bloody hell!
Well. Some of it is still on the table.
Well, that was a bit disappointing
because nothing broke so,
I think what we do is just to get a bit
of smashing action from this video
is give it a right, good messing up.
Ready?
Yeah, yeah!
Well, that worked a treat.
As you can see, it took
care of most of that.
We geniously put down this ground sheet
to catch all the pieces,
but as you can see,
that's quite...
in the wrong place.
Better get cleaning.
Yeah.
Look at the bat it's got China in it.
Give it a little rotate. Oh.
Wedged in there.
Look at that, look at that!
Gnarly.